so I am here with Juana condor from all
to all the boys I've loved before on
Netflix I love it so much and so good
okay we are here tonight celebrating
kids what was the best part about being
a kid the best part about being a kid
was oh packed lunches packed lunch it's
like you know your parents actually just
give you lunch pack of the little box it
was so easy I think that was the best
that I'm just honestly like watching
kids toys like I did that when I was a
kid as well so this amazing to be here
huh yeah okay that's cool
who's your celebrity Idol growing up and
did you ever get to meet them my
celebrity idol growing up I think it was
Vanessa Hudgens from High School Musical
for a long time and then Emily Blunt and
I have yet to meet both of them so
here's to hoping yeah all right nice the
kids toys Awards is all about slime are
you prepared to get slime maybe have an
extra pair of clothes I'm kind of
prepared kind of please don't we cannot
wait for the sequel to all the boys I've
loved before how excited you to get to
work on it again I'm so excited I'm just
beyond excited we are starting shooting
it really really soon and it's gonna be
amazing so yeah okay what can you tell
us about the sequel where are Larry gene
and Peter when we first see them I can't
tell you anything
gonna be lots of love and sweetness and
awesomeness and some drama oh yeah drama
all right final question we know you and
Noah have really bonded during the first
film what is it being like for you to
just be about me
it's really really amazing he's so
talented and he's an amazing actor and
and we've always gotten along very well
so I couldn't have asked for a better
co-star